(mid-tempo riveting music)
- Welcome to a Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Bart Ehrman who is
the Gray Distinguished
Professor of Theological Studies
at the University of North
Carolina in Chapel Hill.
His new book is God's Problem:
How the Bible Fails to Answer
Our Most Important Question--
Why We Suffer.
He is on the Berkeley campus
as the 2008 Foerster Lecturer.
Bart, welcome to Berkeley.
- Well, thanks for having me, Harry, yes.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Lawrence, Kansas.
- Aha, the Midwest.
- [Bart] Yes.
- And looking back, how do
you think your parents shaped
your thinking about the world?
- Well, it was a fairly
conservative time and place.
So I was born in the mid-50s
and Lawrence is a university town,
so I think it is a little more progressive
than a lot of the rest of Kansas.
But basically it was a pretty
conservative upbringing.
- And what sort of
conversations did you have
around the dinner table?
Politics or religion, the Bible?
- Yes, yes, and yes.
(Harry laughs)
And so, yeah, my parents
were quite interested
in all of the above.
- Aha, and when did you
come to the conclusion
that you might be interested in religion?
I guess you became born again,
as you describe in your
book, in high school.
- Yeah, I had a religious upbringing.
We attended an Episcopal
church when I was a child
and we were active in the church.
But then when I was in high school
I started attending a
Youth for Christ club
which was in the high school.
And looking back it seems
a little strange to me
that I needed to be born again.
I'm not sure what I'd been born from,
since I already was a
religious Episcopalian,
but I think the idea was
that I needed to have
a personal relationship
with God through Christ,
and so that's what happened.
Then when I was maybe 16 years old,
and I became a very committed
and hard-hitting Evangelical Christian.
- And I gather that you see
the origins of your commitment
to scholarship during the same period.
I believe you say you
became ill in high school,
and tell us what happened as a result.
- Well, yeah, I wasn't a
brilliant scholar in high school,
I was fine, I did well, but I actually,
between my junior and
senior years in high school,
I was playing baseball
actually and I got sick.
I got hepatitis and it kept
me from playing baseball,
and it kept me homebound,
and I decided to start working
on the debate topic for that year.
I was on the debate team,
and I threw myself into it
the way I had thrown myself
into athletics before this.
And after a while, I was
just completely absorbed
by the idea of books, and reading,
and knowledge, and research.
And so, I trace my becoming
a scholar to that moment
in my life when I really
became intensely involved
with a high school debate topic.
- And then where did you
do your undergraduate work?
- So then, since I had had
this born again experience,
I thought that to be a
really committed Christian.
I needed to have Christian training,
and so my options were to be
on the debate team at Kansas University
or to go off to a Christian school.
I decided that I really
wanted to be committed,
and so I went to Moody
Bible Institute in Chicago,
which was a three-year degree program
where I studied Bible and theology.
Graduated from there,
and then I went to Wheaton
College in Illinois,
which is Billy Graham's alma
mater to finish out my degree.
- And then from there it
was on to graduate school
at Princeton, at the theological
studies program there.
- Yeah, that's right.
So, when I was at Wheaton,
I took as my foreign language Greek.
I wanted to do that because
the Bible is written in Greek,
the New Testament is written in Greek.
And to understand it fully, of course,
you need to be able to read
it in the original language.
And so, I took Greek at Wheaton,
and it turned out I was pretty good at it.
And I decided I wanted
to do my graduate work
on the Greek manuscripts
of the New Testament.
And as it turns out, the leading
expert of that in America
taught at Princeton Theological Seminary,
a man named Bruce Metzger,
and he was at the end of his career
and I wanted to study with him.
And so, I went to Princeton
Theological Seminary
and the only degree option
for me there was a divinity degree,
so I was actually
trained to be a minister.
But I was really more interested
in the academic side of
things and continued on then
and did a Ph.D. there in
the Greek New Testament.
- And along the route of your
education in religious studies
did you have any mentors
other than Metzger
that really influenced you,
that kind of narrowed the focus
of where you wanted to
go in your research?
- I had a number of people,
my Greek teacher in college,
a fellow named Gerry Hawthorne,
who was very influential on me.
And I had several other
professors at Princeton Seminary.
Most of them were New Testament scholars
and they were of varying degrees
of theological persuasion.
Some of them were rather
conservative, as Bruce Metzger was.
Others were on the other side
of the theological spectrum.
And so, I think I was exposed
to a wide range of things
there that otherwise,
prior to that, I hadn't been exposed to.
- And after you getting your degree,
you were actually a minister
to a congregation in
Princeton, New Jersey?
- That's right, I was the pastor
of the Princeton Baptist
Church for a year.
It was when I had actually
started my teaching.
I graduated from Princeton
Seminary with my Ph.D.
and I started teaching
at Rutgers University.
And while I was doing my teaching,
I was also, for one year,
the pastor of this
American Baptist church.
It wasn't a conservative
southern Baptist church,
it was fairly liberal.
By this time, I had become fairly liberal
in my views of things,
and so I pastored this
church for a year, yeah.
- So, help us understand
what an academic committed
to theological studies,
or a scholar of the
literature of the Bible,
what is it exactly that you do?
(both laugh)
- Yes, right, good question.
So, I think roughly speaking,
very roughly speaking,
there are two kinds of people
who do the sorts of things I do.
There are some people who
are theologically oriented,
who teach in divinities and seminaries,
who are in the business of
training people to be ministers.
And so, those are the kinds of professors
that I studied with,
people training ministers.
But also, there's another type of scholar
who works outside of a divinity context,
and that's where I started
working at Rutgers University,
which is the state
university of New Jersey.
It's a secular university,
And after teaching there,
I've been teaching since 1988
at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill.
In this context, religion
professors are teaching
about religion rather than
trying to affirm religion,
or trying to convey religion.
They're teaching about religion the way
political scientists teach
about political science.
They're not necessarily committed
to a particular point of view,
and they're not trying to espouse
a particular point of view,
or trying to evangelize anybody.
They're simply teaching about religion,
in my case teaching about
ancient Christianity
and the New Testament as
part of ancient Christianity.
- So, if students were
interested in going this route,
what can you tell 'em about the skills
that are required to do this work?
Obviously languages.
- Yeah, languages, but the
religious studies department
at Chapel Hill, or anywhere else
where there're religious
studies departments,
are usually parts of the humanities.
And so, the kinds of
skills are the same skills
that students would have
if they were studying
classics, or philosophy, or history,
or actually any of the
humanities or social sciences.
Religion is understood as
an important historical
and cultural phenomenon,
and it needs to be studied
as other historical and
cultural phenomena are studied.
And so, that involves looking
at the literatures of religions,
looking at practices of religions,
looking at philosophical
undergirdings of religions,
and so forth.
During this time, when I was teaching,
I mean, the part we've left out so far is
that I moved away from my
conservative religious beliefs.
And I was teaching not as
somebody who was intent
on converting people to
some kind of religion,
I was actually just a
historian of ancient religion.
- And this is a point I wanted
to go to next, which is,
as one looks at your story as recounted
as kind of a sidebar in your book,
God's Problem, you're on
two trajectories, basically.
That is, very early you
become a person of faith,
drawing on your youthful
enthusiasm and strong beliefs,
and on that trajectory, and
then another trajectory,
which you've just described,
is that of you know evidence,
historical analysis, a search for truth
in the secular way of doing
these things at the university.
And I get the sense
that at a certain point
these two trajectories weren't
going on a parallel course,
that they crossed in one
way and you chose the other.
Talk a little about that.
- Well, no, that's exactly right.
I think I got interested in
pursuing the study of religion
when I was a born again Christian
and was interested in knowing
more about this faith,
and that drove me into scholarship
because I wanted to learn more and more.
But the more I pursued scholarship,
the more I saw that
scholarship at many points was
at odds with my religious convictions.
And so, over time I had to deal with this
on the personal level, which is,
it's quite unlike most academics.
My wife is an expert in
medieval English drama
and this does not cut up
against her personal beliefs in any way,
and so it's how she's chosen
to pursue her academic life.
But in my case, my academic
life was originally driven
by personal religious convictions
and then came to create tension
with my personal religious convictions,
and something had to give,
and what gave were my convictions.
- And it struck me as
I was reading your book
that there's an element
of courage involved
in the path that you took.
And by that, I mean
you must have believed,
and you must have believed strongly,
and then these two
worlds clashed in a way.
And at a certain point you
have to confront yourself
in the mirror and say, well, you know,
I have to wonder about this.
- Yes, well, as it turns out,
it's very difficult emotionally
to move away from a perspective,
religious perspective,
religious world view
that you've held deeply.
I see this with my own
students at Chapel Hill
where my students, many of them,
come from conservative Baptist backgrounds
and they're very committed to
the Bible and their beliefs.
And when I teach the New Testament
from a historical perspective,
bracketing the question of belief,
and they learn historical information
about the New Testament,
it actually confronts them with things
that they're not comfortable with.
And it does create a good
deal of emotional turmoil
that is fairly unusual in the
world of academics, I think.
But if one is gonna be a serious academic,
one needs to, of course,
engage in the study and things
fall out as they do, yeah.
- In looking at your work
and the textual analysis you
do in the course of this book,
and some of your other
books which I looked at,
it's very clear that comparative
historical studies are
very important as you look at these texts.
And I wanna talk a little about that
'cause it seems to be very important.
So, you're looking at a work
that we know as the Bible,
or some piece of it,
and what are the questions
one has to ask about that work
when you're trying to understand
its multiple meanings?
- Yeah, the study of the Bible,
especially the New Testament,
which is what I'm particularly expert in,
is a complicated affair
because a lot of people
read the New Testament
and a lot of people have
opinions about the New Testament,
but scholarship on the New
Testament tends to be different
from the popular reading
of the New Testament.
In part, just for the
reason that you mentioned,
that to understand the New Testament,
one really has to situate it
in its own historical context.
When people read the New Testament today,
mainly the people who
read it are believers
who simply assume that this is
speaking to them in some way.
But the historians want to know
what these books are as
first century documents.
These are written by Christians
in the first century who were living
in a particular time and particular place
with a particular set of
assumptions about the world,
with a particular set of assumptions
about how religion works,
and one needs to understand these writings
within their own historical context.
And once one does that,
once one engages with these books
from the point of view of history,
they start looking very different
from the way that they look
to just simple believers
who are reading the text
for personal reasons.
- Is there a moment early in
these two phases of your life
where, you know, a light bulb went off,
or was this transition
to full-time scholar
from part-time evangelical,
was this the culmination of years,
or was there some moment that came?
And here I'm not as much interested,
we'll talk a minute about
how you watched suffering
and how that was a key part, but really,
I'm interested in the contrast
between these two worlds.
- Yeah, well, there were a
number of aha moments for me
when I realized that
there's a tension here,
and one of the early ones, I mean,
it sounds a little bit silly
now, looking back on it,
but I had done a term paper
for a class I was taking.
In seminary, one takes courses
on a book of the New Testament
will be the entire course.
And so I was taking a book on the exegesis
or the interpretation
of the Gospel of Mark.
And one of the problems with the Gospels
that historians have long noted is
that there are a number of
discrepancies among them,
and contradictions, and they
have different perspectives,
and how does one grapple with this.
And I was dealing, I wrote a term paper
on a specific passage
in the Gospel of Mark.
It's a tiny little detail
but there's this passage in Mark
where Jesus' disciples are
accused by the Pharisees
of eating grain on the Sabbath.
And Jesus tries to defend them by saying
that these Pharisees should
remember what happened
when King David went into the temple
and ate the shewbread
which is only supposed to
be eaten by the priests.
And they did this when
Abiathar was the high priest.
And so, Jesus backs them down
with this reference to the Hebrew Bible.
The problem is that when you actually read
the Hebrew Bible passage about
this in the Book of Samuel,
it's not Abiathar, the high priest,
who is reigning at the time,
it's his father, Ahimelech.
And so, I wrote this 35-page
paper trying to explain
how it was that even though
Mark said it was Abiathar
that was the high priest, in fact,
what he meant was that it
was Ahimelech (laughs).
In other words, I was trying
to reconcile a contradiction,
and I spent 35 pages of
detailed interpretation,
dealing with the Greek text
and the grammatical problems
of the Greek text in
order to argue this point.
And at the end of this paper,
my professor who was a
very pious Christian man
simply wrote a comment where he said
maybe Mark made a mistake.
(both laugh)
- [Harry] I see.
- And it just blew open
the whole thing for me.
I realized I had gone to all this effort
to try and show that, in fact,
there's not a contradiction here
but it's just much simpler
to say it's a mistake.
And once that happened I
started realizing that, in fact,
there are a lot of mistakes
in the Bible, contradictions,
discrepancies, different points of view,
different authors have different things
that they have to say
about fundamental issues
about who Jesus is, who
God is, what salvation is.
And so that the Bible is
not a unified monolith.
In fact, it's a book that has lots
of different points of
view represented in it.
- And this is an important point
because you're dealing with the
problem of the human author.
I'm not talking about Jesus now,
but obviously, you
know, the disciples who,
as you just said, make mistakes.
But it's also these works
come to us after translations,
and so on, that add another
layer of mixed meanings.
- Yes, absolutely, it's very,
my older view that the Bible
is the inspired word of God
with no errors in it, came
under fire for just this reason.
We don't have the originals
of any of the copies of the New Testament,
or of the Hebrew Bible either.
What we have are copies that
were made centuries later,
in most cases, by scribes,
some of whom weren't very good,
and these copies that we have
all have changes in them.
This is what my earlier book
on misquoting Jesus was about,
is that we have thousands of copies
and these thousands of copies have
hundreds of thousands
of differences in them.
And I got to a point where it
no longer made sense for me
to say that God had inspired
the words of this text
because we don't have
the words of this text.
And so, what would be the point
of even saying God had inspired them?
We don't have them.
And so, this was another
sort of moment for me
when I realized that, in fact,
this older belief of mine
simply wasn't credible.
- Now an important theme in
your book is your own experience
in addressing the question
of human suffering,
was also a catalyst for this transition
to, you know, just being
a scholar, in essence.
But at the same time, you continued to be,
I guess, a humanitarian,
or somebody focused on, you
know, the problems of the world
and finding your commitment
to faith as not giving
you the answers as you
worked through the text.
Talk a little about that
because it's a very human sense
of not just your suffering
but the problem of suffering,
which leads to changes in your thinking.
- That's right, when I
was pastoring this church
in New Jersey was when I was moving away,
in many ways, from my Christian faith.
And one of the things that
happened in those years was
that I was teaching at Rutgers
and was asked to teach a
class at Rutgers called
the problem of suffering
in the Biblical traditions.
It was a class that was on the books
and they needed somebody to teach it.
They asked me to teach it.
And I thought it'd be an
interesting class to teach
because I think a lot of
the authors of the Bible are
wrapped up with just this
question, why is there suffering?
And so, I taught this class at Rutgers,
and it got me thinking
deeply about the very problem
of suffering and why there's suffering.
And I realized in the course
of teaching this class
that different Biblical
authors have different answers
to why they're suffering.
That a lot of these answers are not
answers people would have today,
and a lot of these answers
are at odds with one another.
And this drove me deeper
into trying to understand
how we can explain this
world that we live in
with so much pain and misery in it.
If there is, as the Bible says,
a good and all-powerful
God who's in charge of it,
if there is a God who's
in control of this world,
why is there massive starvation?
Why are there hurricanes?
Why are there tsunamis?
Why are there earthquakes?
Why are there genocides?
Why is there a Holocaust?
I mean, all of these things
became very pressing issues for me,
as I started thinking more
and more about the world
and the relationship to some
kind of true God, ultimate God.
- And when you were a minister
you mentored and nurtured
a Cambodian family,
and you talk about that in the book.
Tell us a little about that
because that was kind of a
personal way that this hit you.
- Yeah, it was actually
right after I stopped being
the pastor of this church in New Jersey.
I decided that I wanted to be involved
in some kind of social work,
and I hooked up with the
Lutheran Social Services.
And they had me tutor a
family, a Cambodian family,
in English as a second language.
And so, every week I would go over
to this family's apartment
in Trenton, New Jersey.
The fellow's name was Marcei
Noun and his wife, Sufi.
And we would spend an hour
or two working on English.
And as I worked with them
over the weeks and months,
it became clear they had gone
through horrible suffering themselves.
They had been in Cambodia
during the purge of the Khmer Rouge,
and had lived in Phnom Penh.
And had been driven out of
the city with everyone else
when they depopulated
the cities in Cambodia,
and had been put in slave labor camps.
And as I talked with them more,
I realized just the horrors
they had gone through,
very much like the movie,
The Killing Fields.
And they had escaped finally.
Marcei had tracked down
his wife and children
and they escaped under cover of night
over the mountains into Thailand,
and had been put into a refugee camp.
And then had been brought
to the United States
by the Lutheran Social Services.
- And you were struggling
with comprehending
how they could have gone
through this, I guess,
these experiences in Cambodia.
- Well, they were horrible experiences,
and this is a case where a good deal
of the suffering is
simply caused by humans.
I mean, Pol Pot's regime
was awful, and so on the--
- And of course, our
bombing of Cambodia was one
of the factors that
helped create that regime.
- No, it's what started the whole thing.
And so, there were a number
of factors leading into it,
including American policy
in Vietnam, to begin with.
But then the question was,
I mean, on a deeper level,
you can explain why on a
political level this happens.
But on a deeper level,
as somebody who was
still a person of faith,
I had to ask myself, why does
this sort of thing happen?
And how does one explain this?
If one believes that there's
a God who answers prayer,
for example, I mean,
what is the evidence of
that, exactly, in Cambodia?
I'd say there's virtually
no evidence of it,
and this is what began making me challenge
my previous faith in a
good and all powerful God.
- And this becomes the goal of your book,
which you conceived of
30 years, or so, back,
but only now have written.
And so, give us an
understanding of how you set out
with this problem in mind to
do the research that you do.
- Yeah, so, well, I taught
this class at Rutgers
and I thought it was an interesting topic,
about how different Biblical
authors deal with suffering.
You know, the biggest problem
I had at Rutgers, actually,
was convincing my 19- and 20-year-old,
New Jersey middle class, white students
that there was a problem.
(both laugh)
- [Harry] That there was suffering.
- Yeah, that suffering existed
and there was a problem of it.
And so, this was during, it was actually
during one of the Ethiopian famines.
And I resorted to doing things
like bringing in pictures
from the newspaper of
women starving to death
with children on their
breasts starving to death,
and pointing to these pictures and saying
look, this is a problem.
And so, I think the students got the idea
by the end of the semester.
But then when the term ended I thought,
I'd really like to write about this,
about how different Biblical
authors struggle with it.
But then I thought, you
know, I'm only 30 years old.
I'm not really old enough
to write about suffering.
I need to live a while longer.
And so, a couple of years ago,
after I'd written a bunch of
other books on other topics,
I thought, you know, I'd like to go back
to that question of suffering.
And then I thought, no, you're
too young to write the book.
But then I realized that when I'm 80,
I'm going to say, I'm too
young to write the book.
(both laugh)
And so, I thought, well,
I'll just go ahead and do it.
And so, over these intervening years
I've continued to think about
it, and to read about it,
and so I decided to devote
some serious research time
into how the Bible authors
deal with this problem.
And my book is the result of that.
- So, let's talk about this,
and let's take one answer
of the Bible at a time
and see what we can draw out of you
about the way you study problems,
in addition to explicating what the,
you know, Bible has to say.
So, the first item that
goes back in the Bible
to the beginning of the
Bible, the Old Testament,
what was the answer there?
What were we told in that
work about why we suffer?
- Well, one of the oldest answers
that you get in the Bible,
and an answer that pervades
much of the Hebrew Bible,
and is found in the New Testament as well,
is the answer that you find
in the early Hebrew prophets.
And it doesn't really matter
which prophet you read,
whether it's Isaiah, Jeremiah,
Ezekiel, Hosea, Joel, Amos.
All of these prophets
basically have the same view.
The question they're dealing
with is why is it that Israel,
the people of God, suffer?
And the solution in the prophets is
that the reason the
people of God suffer is
because they have violated God's will,
they've broken the Torah, the law,
and God is punishing them.
God is punishing them
to get them to repent
so they're return to him.
And if they return to him
then things will be fine,
and the suffering will abate.
And so, you find there's page after page
after page of these prophets,
so that the basic answer they give is
that suffering comes as
a punishment for sins.
- Give us one story that is
an example of this that really
makes the point which is
repeated again and again.
- Well, it starts off,
it's not just the prophets,
it's the entire historical
narratives of the Hebrew Bible.
I mean the Bible begins with Adam and Eve
being told not to eat
the fruit in the Garden.
They eat the fruit and
they're punished as a result.
They're kicked out of the Garden.
Adam now has to work and get his bread
by the sweat of his brow.
Eve now, when she bears children,
will experience terrible pain.
These are curses put on them
by God because they disobeyed.
And as the narrative goes on,
this theme keeps getting repeated.
The entire world,
eventually all of the
human race is wicked,
and so God decides to punish
them by sending a flood.
And so he kills everybody on Earth,
except for Noah and his close family.
And it goes from there,
you can read this narrative
throughout the entire Hebrew Bible.
The sequence is that people sin,
it leads to punishment from God.
If it leads to repentance, good enough,
if not, then more punishment comes.
- And as we'll move to the
second solution in the Bible,
but the question arises,
as you move from solution to solution,
is it that the previous solution,
or the one that has dominated,
or the one that has come
first, has proven inadequate?
Is that what's going on here,
in your mind as a scholar?
- That's part of it.
Some of the subsequent
solutions come about precisely
because the earlier
solutions don't seem to work.
I mean, the problem with saying
that suffering comes
as a penalty for sin is
that you can't explain
why the righteous suffer.
You would expect, under
the prophetic scenario,
that the people suffering all
the time would be the wicked,
and the righteous would be prosperous,
but it obviously doesn't work that way.
And so, other solutions have to be devised
in order to explain that.
There are other solutions
that are probably
independent of one another.
There're a lot of smart
people in ancient Israel
and among early Christians,
and they had lots of different views,
and they weren't all just
reacting to one another.
But this kind of progressive
idea certainly generated
a number of the solutions
that you get in the Bible.
- And the second solution is what?
- Well, so it's not a sequence
of one, two, three and four.
(both laugh)
- Yeah, right, we're doing
the sequence of your book
as opposed to, but here we have
to find another explanation,
and maybe it's what man does to man.
- Yeah, well, the prophets
actually realized this,
that not all suffering comes
because of God punishing people.
The reason God punishes people is
because people are doing
bad things to other people.
And so, there's implicit
in that, of course,
the understanding that a
lot of evil happens simply
because people are wicked, or
they behave in a wicked way.
This is the closest thing
that you get in the Bible to what is now,
among Christians anyway,
the prominent explanation.
The prominent explanation
among Christians is
that the reason there's
suffering in the world is
because people have free will.
God has given people free will.
If he hadn't given them free will,
they would be programmed
like robots simply to do
what God had asked them to do.
But since they have free will,
they have the freedom not only
to love God but also to hate.
They have the freedom not only to do good
but also to do evil.
And so, necessarily there
is suffering in the world
because of the existence of free will.
And so, the Bible doesn't quite go at it
in those philosophical terms,
but it certainly understands
that human beings can do nasty things
to other human beings,
And that's one of the reasons
there's so much suffering.
- As you're looking at these
answers, and you pointed out,
that there were bright people
in these religious communities
who were thinking about these issues,
but what other things should we look at,
you as a historian, you know,
in terms of their social milieu,
the historical forces at work.
One of the things that
comes up again and again is
this was all happening
in areas of the world
that were being conquered
by one empire after another.
- Yeah, well, it's not an accident
that the Biblical authors are
so taken up with suffering,
I mean, just precisely
because of their historical situation.
Israel, of course, is located at a place
that was a very desirable
place for anybody wanting
to to have, claim to be a world empire.
So it's situated roughly
on the fertile crescent
between Babylon and
Assyria over to the east,
and Egypt to the southwest.
And anybody who wants to
control that whole area has
to control the land that Israel claimed.
And so, Israel continually,
on top of regular natural disasters
that anybody in the ancient world had,
famine, and drought, and
pestilence, and so forth,
Israel had the problem
of constantly being
conquered by other countries.
And so, in the 8th century BCE,
it's conquered by the Assyrians.
In the 6th century, by the Babylonians,
later by the Persians,
later by the Romans,
and the Greeks, the
Romans, and so it goes.
And these prophets, in fact,
were responding precisely
to these situations and saying,
the reason Assyria has overthrown you is
because you've sinned.
If you hadn't sinned, it
wouldn't have happened.
But then some people
looked around and noticed
that the righteous people in
Israel suffered just as much
from the Assyrians as the wicked did,
and so they have to have
some other explanation.
- And the third alternative
here is suffering as redemption,
which becomes very important
in the New Testament.
- It does, and it becomes
probably the key motif
in the New Testament's
understanding of suffering,
but it's found already in
the Hebrew Bible, as well.
- In the story of Joseph,
you mentioned, yeah.
- Oh, the story of Joseph
in the Book of Genesis.
Joseph is sold by his brothers as a slave
and ends up in Egypt as
a slave to a household.
And so this is not a great life.
He's eventually thrown in prison
for being falsely accused of rape,
and very bad things are happening to him.
But the way the story works
is that God is working
behind the scenes all along the way,
so that at the end Joseph is
elevated to a position of power
in the government of Egypt.
And he's able to bring
salvation to his family
that's starving to
death back in Palestine.
And they come to Egypt
and he's able to provide
them with what they need.
And so, they are saved from a dire famine
because of Joseph's suffering, indirectly.
And so suffering can sometimes
have a silver lining,
or sometimes suffering actually brings
salvation of some sort.
That's the view that gets picked up,
of course, in the New Testament
where Jesus himself suffers
for the sake of salvation.
And so, in that view,
salvation is directly
a result of suffering.
- And then we move,
well, not sequentially,
but another alternative here
is that God is all powerful
and we have to accept that,
and you find this in Job.
- Job is a very interesting
book, and of course,
you know, any book that
talks about suffering
in the Bible has to talk about Job.
What people frequently
don't understand about Job,
I'd say most readers of
Job don't understand,
is what scholars have
recognized for a very long time,
which is that Job actually
has two different authors
with two different books
that have been put together into one book.
And so, the book people
are familiar with is
the beginning and the end of the story,
where you have Job who's
a very righteous man.
And because he's so righteous,
he has thousands of cattle,
and thousands of sheep,
he has a great family,
seven sons, three daughters,
and he's got a terrific life.
And the Satan, the sort of
devil's advocate up in heaven,
tells God that the only
reason Job is righteous is
because he's getting everything out of it.
And God and Satan, in effect, have a bet
that Satan can get Job to curse God.
And Satan does his
worst, it doesn't happen.
Job doesn't curse God,
he's a patient sufferer
even though everything
is taken away from him,
his camels, his sheep, his possessions,
his children are killed,
everything is taken away,
but he still doesn't curse God.
And so, then God rewards him.
He rewards him by giving him back
twice as much of everything he had before.
So he got twice as many
sheep, camel, servants,
he gets 10 children back,
and dies a happy, old man.
So, in this view of suffering in Job,
suffering comes as a test of faith.
Will you remain faithful
even if things aren't good?
And if you do, then you'll get rewarded.
That's a powerful story.
I find it offensive, actually, in part.
What I find especially
offensive is this idea
that Job can be given
back 10 other children
as if the murder of 10 children,
you know, that can be made all right
by the substitution of
10 additional children.
I find that completely offensive,
but that's one of the views of Job,
this narrative at the
beginning and the end.
What people don't realize is
that the middle part of Job
is written by somebody else.
It's not written as a story,
it's written as a series of poems
in which Job and his three
so-called friends have dialogues
about why Job is suffering.
And the friends take the
prophets' point of view,
that Job is suffering because
he's done things wicked,
and God's punishing him.
And Job insists he's not
wicked, he's innocent.
He hasn't done anything wrong.
And after chapter after chapter
of them going back and forth,
Job finally demands that God appear to him
so that he can state his case
and show that he doesn't deserve this.
And God appears out of the whirlwind,
but instead of explaining to
Job why he suffered, you know,
Job, well, it was actually
a bet that I had with Satan,
or it was a test to see if you'd be strong
but you've passed the test.
Or instead of giving some explanation
what God does is he
overwhelms Job with his power
and begins by saying,
"Where were you when I laid
the foundations of the earth?"
And he starts in on Job
telling him that he's almighty
and Job is a mere peon,
and basically he squashes Job in the dust.
And Job ends this poetry by saying,
"I repent in dust and ashes."
Well, he repents, he
didn't do anything wrong,
but since God is almighty
and Job is a mere mortal,
he has no right to question the almighty
about why he's suffering.
So, that's the answer to the poetry.
- It's interesting here
because of the textual
analysis you're doing
and the work of your scholarship.
You actually unravel layers of
subtlety and complexity here,
which is interesting (laughs).
I'm just commenting, it's a comment.
- Yeah, well, I think to understand Job
without that kind of unraveling
of its different parts,
Job doesn't make any sense (laughs).
But I think when you
look at it in this way,
that you actually have
two different authors
whose books have been spliced together,
and you realize that, in fact,
the patient Job of the
beginning and end isn't
the impatient Job of the poetry.
And that the view of suffering
at the beginning and end
isn't the view of the middle of the book,
it actually then makes better sense.
- Now Ecclesiastes and the
vision there is the one
that you seem most to relate to.
- Yeah, I do,
I think the Book of
Ecclesiastes is maybe underread.
It's a terrific little book.
It claims to be written by Solomon,
the wisest man ever to have lived.
But in fact, it was written
hundreds of years later.
Scholars who are linguistic
experts in Hebrew can date books
on the basis of the style of the writing,
It's pretty clear this is a later book,
somebody claiming to
be Solomon, who wasn't.
The point of the book can be found
at the very beginning
where the author says,
vanity of vanities, all is vanity.
The word vanity is a Hebrew word, hevel,
which means, it's something like
the mist that's around for a little while
and then burns off and it disappears.
So, it means something that's transient,
temporary, impermanent, and
that's what all of life is.
This world goes on and on and on,
nothing ever changes.
There's nothing new under the sun,
but we're here just for a little while.
And so, what does one do with that?
Well, the Book of
Ecclesiastes looks around
and sees there's no justice.
And he looks around and sees
we're not here for long,
and his conclusion is
we should eat and drink,
and enjoy our toil, and enjoy our spouse.
He believes that you should
grab the simple pleasures
in life for as long as you can
because this life is all you have.
There's no afterlife,
this isn't a dress rehearsal
for something else.
It's not a dry run, this is it.
And so you should enjoy life
for all it's worth while you can.
- One of the solutions that
you discuss has appeared
to have greater relevance in our time
because of the way it
appears to have intruded
on American politics.
And here we're talking
about the apocalyptic vision
to solve this problem,
to explain suffering
by the notion of apocalypse.
And your analysis points to the way
that this appears initially
in the Old Testament,
in the Book of Daniel.
Talk a little about that,
and then help us understand
what the key components
were to this answer.
- Yeah, this answer becomes
prominent in early Judaism,
near the end of the Hebrew Bible period
in the Book of Daniel,
which is the last of the
books of the Hebrew Bible--
- And that would have been
what year the hundred uh--
- About 150, 160 BCE.
So, but this view becomes
dominant in the New Testament
and becomes the explanatory
position of the New Testament.
This view is called apocalyptic
because it's based on the
Greek word apokalupsis
which means revealing or an unveiling.
The idea is that God has
revealed the heavenly secrets
that can make sense of earthly realities,
and so God explains why this
world is in the state it's in.
The apocalypticists were reacting
against the prophetic point of view.
The prophets thought that
God was punishing people,
that's why they were suffering.
But the apocalypticists realized
that righteous people are
the ones who are suffering,
and so God must not be punishing them.
So, why are they suffering?
And the apocalypticists
came up with the idea
that there are forces opposed to God
that are creating suffering in the world.
This is the period in
which Jewish thinkers came
to think that God has a
personal enemy, the Devil.
And the Devil has demons who work
his nefarious ways here on earth,
and there're all these cosmic forces
that are creating havoc here on earth.
But God is ultimately going
to establish his sovereignty
over the world by destroying
these forces of evil
and setting up a good kingdom on earth.
And so, the apocalypticists
believed that in the future
God would once again reassert himself
and good would emerge triumphant,
and God's Kingdom would come to replace
these wicked earthly kingdoms on earth.
- Now when you're discussing
the prophet Daniel,
it becomes very interesting
that his prophecies
and descriptions come at a
time when the Greek influence,
and the efforts by the
Greek Empire at that time,
to Hellenize and to stop the
traditional Jewish rituals,
prayers, ways of behaving that
follow the dictates of God,
that this is how we get
the Maccabean Revolt,
which is celebrated by Jews today
as the holiday of Hanukkah.
So, Daniel is a man of his time
who's dealing with real historical forces,
the efforts to colonize this
Jewish community in Judea,
and his language becomes
very metaphorical, basically.
- Yeah, that's right.
So, this was an awful time period
for people living in Israel.
The monarch of Syria, who
was trying to Hellenize,
trying to make Israel Greek,
basically outlawed the
possibility of following Torah,
so that to the extent
that women who had their
baby boy circumcised,
the children would be murdered
and hanged around their mothers' necks.
And we learned about this
in some of these books
of First and Second
Maccabees, for example.
And Daniel is responding to this.
He sees this not just as human evil,
bad things that humans do,
he sees it in a bigger
cosmic context that, in fact,
there are forces that are bigger than us
that are at work in this world
that are creating this kind of havoc.
And since these are cosmic forces,
they need to be dealt
with on the cosmic level.
God himself is going to intervene
and destroy these forces of evil,
and get rid of the evil kingdoms
to set up his good kingdom on earth.
- Now and you suggest that when you look
at what they're writing,
it's on the one hand very descriptive,
it's like four chapters have been written
and these are the chapters of where we are
and what has happened to us, and so on.
And that what the
apocalypticists are giving
the people of the time
is the next chapter,
looking ahead to the future.
So, in a way, they're
kind of futurologists.
- Yes, absolutely, in fact,
they use a very interesting ploy.
Daniel, as we said, was probably
written maybe 150, 160 BCE,
but the author claims to be
Daniel living 400 years earlier
under the Babylonian captivity.
And so, this author pretending
to be Daniel 400 years earlier,
predicts what's going
to happen in the future.
But as he's predicting what's
happening in the future,
the real author, of course,
is recounting what's already
happened in the past.
So that the reader reads this
and thinks that this
ancient person was correct
about all of his predictions.
But the author then goes on to predict
what's going to happen next,
and the reader doesn't realize
that now he's changed gears
and is talking about what's
going to happen in the future.
The reader thinks the whole
thing has been a prediction,
but this then provides
validation for his predictions
of this good kingdom that's going to come,
you know, in a matter of months.
And so it provides hope for readers
that, in fact, this has all been foreseen,
it's all been according to plan,
it's all under God's sovereignty.
And if we hold on for a little
while longer, it'll be okay.
- Why do you think that these
kinds of visions have taken
on a new influence, a new power,
and not just today but in
recent years in our culture,
and had such a political impact?
- Well, it's a very good question.
You know, there continue to
be people today who think
that some kind of apocalyptic scenario
like this is going to be played out.
When I was in college in the 1970s,
the best-selling book
in the English language,
this isn't widely known,
the best-selling book
in the English language,
apart from the Bible, was a book called
The Late, Great Planet
Earth by Hal Lindsey,
which was an apocalyptic scenario
about what was going to happen
when war broke out in the Middle East.
And the Soviet Union was gonna march in,
and there was gonna be a
confederate of European nations
that came in to oppose the Soviets,
and a nuclear holocaust was gonna happen.
And this was told as a prediction
of what really was going
to take place based on
prophecies of the Bible,
the Book of Daniel, the Book
of Revelation, and so forth.
This was an extremely popular book,
millions and millions of copies
of this thing were read and believed.
And in our day the Left Behind series,
many people watching
this show may not know
the Left Behind series, but
it was extremely popular.
It sold more copies
than The Da Vinci Code.
And people believe
that there's gonna be this apocalyptic,
and I think it's a very
interesting question,
why it is, especially in
American Christianity,
that it's believed that
this apocalyptic moment
is going to happen.
You know, that people are so
dissatisfied with this world
that they think that it's controlled
by Satan and his henchmen,
and that God's going to
do something about it.
It's a very interesting question,
what exactly the appeal is.
- And is it that, in some
ways, I wanna be careful here,
that the elements of this
make sense at one level,
and that if people of faith
who are looking for explanations
of what's going on in the world,
and they're not sort of
grounded in political analysis
or economic analysis,
that one can see them making that leap.
And when you get a work that purports
to put everything together--
- [Bart] Yes.
- Then you've got an audience?
- Yes, absolutely, these
apocalyptic scenarios
as painted in the Bible, in
the New Testament, for example,
they speak about awful natural disasters.
There'll be earthquakes,
and there'll be hurricanes,
and there'll be, and they
lay out all these disasters,
there'll be wars and rumors of wars.
And of course, every
generation has had earthquakes,
and hurricanes, and tsunamis,
and wars, and rumors of wars.
And so, people who read
the Bible literally think,
oh, this is talking about our day.
And so, this happens,
if you go into a conservative evangelical
Christian bookstore today,
you'll find shelf after shelf
of prophecies coming fulfilled.
You know, this was going
to happen to Israel
and this has happened.
You know, there were
supposed to be disasters
and look what happened,
we had tsunamis, we
had Katrina, et cetera.
And so, things are being
fulfilled in our own day.
- Given your background as a person
who brings historical
analysis to these texts,
you seem to be in a unique position
to address a very
important question, namely,
how are people of faith drawn
to the present situation
in a more progressive way,
so that their faith leads
them to be concerned
about the environment?
So that their faith leads them
to the humanitarian concerns
that, you know, are a
theme throughout your book?
And I'm curious, does your
perch, your portfolio,
as somebody who starts
as a person of faith,
moves away from that but
continues to study, you know,
these issues as they appear back in time
and contributes to the
interpretation of text,
is there an answer there
that you can help us see a way toward?
- Yeah, you know, I think
one of the most hopeful signs
on the religious scene is
that a large number of people
on the religious right have taken up
important social issues.
The reason this is a hopeful sign is
because the apocalyptic
scenario that I just painted out
has often led to social complacency.
If, you know, if the end is coming
and God's gonna make
right all that's wrong,
and God is gonna resolve
all of our problems,
then there's no point in us really
sort of doing much about it now
because we can't do much about it.
But Christians of the far right
have started realizing that,
in fact, if God is going
to do this in the future,
we ought to be doing
something about it now.
And so you find people
who are typically conservative Christians,
who are now supporting things,
like environmental issues, global warming,
and concern for world
poverty, and issues like that,
which have traditionally
been more liberal issues.
But they're being taken up by
these conservative Christians
because they realize that
their theology, in fact,
virtually requires them to be
concerned about these things.
And so, I see that actually as
one of the more hopeful signs
on the political scene right now,
in terms of what's going on
with the religious right.
- How do you advise students
to prepare for the future?
Because presumably it's not just students
who wanna become ministers
who are in your classes
at the University of North Carolina,
but also people of faith
who wanna deal, you know, with
the problems of the world.
Is there some advice
that you would give them,
in terms of their studies,
in preparing to address those problems?
- Yeah, you know, the strange
situation that one is in,
teaching religion in
a secular institution,
is that you're teaching a
subject about which, I mean,
you can't promote a particular
aspect of your subject
because of the separation
of church and state.
So, I do get students
who are planning on going on to ministry,
but by far, my students are
simply people taking the class
because they're interested
in taking a class
in the New Testament, you
know, along with their classes
in philosophy and history
and classics, or whatever.
But what I try to do in my
classes is actually fairly basic.
I mean I do try to get
students to understand
that you have these different
perspectives in the Bible.
Whether you're a person of faith or not,
the Bible contains a
lot of different answers
to a lot of different issues,
so that I'm trying to get them to see
that you can't simply, you
know, rest on the Bible,
the way that many of my students
in North Carolina think they can do.
But basically, what I'm trying to do is
to do what I think every
university professor needs to do,
which is to get students to think more.
And teaching Bible in the South is
a perfect way to get this to happen
because students come in
with a vested commitment
and interest in the subject matter,
unlike almost any other
subject they're taking.
And if you disabuse them
of many of their perspectives
and their assumptions,
it forces them to think.
So that they have to come
up with solutions themselves
for things that otherwise they thought
were gonna be handed to
them on a silver platter.
This makes them, I think,
not only more interesting
and more able to deal
with religious diversity,
but also with political
diversity, for example.
Instead of simply accepting
what their parents told them
about the political situation,
they're forced to think about it.
And so, that's really kind of my strategy,
I think, is to get students
to reflect on big issues
and to realize that there are
multiple views represented.
And that one has to come
to some kind of decision
based on rational thought
about what position one wants
to take, whether religiously,
politically, economically,
or anything else.
- Well, on that note, Bart,
I wanna thank you very
much for being here.
Let me show our audience your book again,
which has actually been
on the best seller list, God's Problem.
And I wanna thank you again.
- Okay, well, thank you.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation With History.
(mid-tempo riveting music)